What we've been working
on for the past year
almost year is just kind
of the training method that I do.
And it's the same training
method that I use for Kim.
It's mostly about eating.
I mean, people think it's in the exercise,
but if you're not eating
right consistently,
then it's just never going to happen.
You know, her diet has come a long way
and has changed a lot in terms of
just eliminating processed
foods and just getting
her to eat real food.
So if it comes in a box,
if it didn't grow off a tree or
the earth didn't give it to you,
then just stay away from it.
Fresh foods, unprocessed
foods and only water.
As for the work outs,
I would do something that's mixed,
so that there's weight training,
there's high intensity interval training
and there's steady state cardio.
For now, you know I train Kim
consistently. Sometimes I train
her sisters Khloe and Kourtney.
Kim: She's even Snapchatting
in my workout with Melissa.
I give her the privilege of working out
with her one time.
I honestly, I just love her.
She's also like one of the best clients
that you could ever have.
She doesn't cancel. She's always there.
- [Kim] This is what I'm doing today.
A lot of our sessions are at 6 a.m.
I wake up at 4.
So we train about five, six days a week.
It ranges from an hour
to an hour and a half.
We do a lot of squats,
dead lifts, chest press,
overhead press,
a ton of sprints.
We do pull-ups, dips,
but I would
say that 85% of our
training is weight training.
You have to put the work in.
You have to be intense,
you have to struggle with
every rep and feel it.
It doesn't mean that
you're gonna be Arnold and get huge.
- [Kim] Hey guys, she's trying to kill me.
- Only a little bit.
- [Kim] Officially trying to kill me.
- In the beginning, I
was sitting on my couch.
I had gained 70 pounds with my daughter
and I saw this infomercial
for Insanity, which is
a home workout program.
And I saw these people's transformations.
And I packed up all my food,
I never cheated, only drank water,
never missed a workout
and 60 days later I was 40 pounds lighter.
I decided I wanted to do
a bodybuilding competition
in December of 2015. I won first place
in Miss Figure and Miss
Physique and that's
when Kim contacted me.
So she saw my transformation
picture on Instagram.
She was scrolling through
Instagram at 4 o'clock
in the morning and she was
like, "Wow, this woman,
she's a Mom. She lives
like a regular life.
Look at how she changed her life."
She was looking for something
that was sustainable.
She didn't want to just
lose weight fast and then
you know gain it again. It's a lifestyle.
I had no expectations of
becoming a celebrity trainer.
I'm not thinking, "Oh yeah,
I'm gonna train Oprah tomorrow."
I just hope that they
get the results they're looking for.
And every time she sees
a new muscle growing
or new lines, new definition -
- [KIm] Do you guys see my muscles?
- The look on her face
just makes me like
super excited for her,
because I know exactly
what that feels like.
- Hamstrings, my favorite.
- Yeah, except that you're doing it
with that bar.
- Oh, she has the light bar.
This is what I'm doing.
- Exactly.